des nouvelles salles d'enseignement
douze mille cinq cents mètres carrés
d'espacé neufs ou restructurés ou encore
la reconstruction du gymnase le bilan
des deux ans de travaux du lycée franco
allemand de buc comme ses parasols
géants avec plusieurs utilités donc les
fameux bar azoles qui sont la signature
architecturale
son régal récupérateurs d'eau de pluie
pour pouvoir être recyclés sur
l'arrosage de l'établissement où les
sanitaires également et ses parasols ont
donc une double utilité voire une triple
utilité puisqu'il abrite également du
soleil et de la pluie au total 56
millions d'euros ont été investis un
projet financé par la région ile de
france et le département des yvelines un
établissement important dans le cadre de
l'amitié franco allemande la première
pierre de la rénovation était posée le
22 janvier 2022 date d'anniversaire du
traité de l'elysée signé en 1963 pour
sceller la réconciliation entre la
france et la république fédérale
d'allemagne c'est un des rares lycée qui
était prévu par un traité international
lé lycée franco-allemand il ya trois en
europe donc de en france un en allemagne
et ça a été voulu pour marquer la
réconciliation franco-allemande donc
c'est aussi un lieu historique un lieu
politique au sens le plus noble de ce
terme et savoir que dans cet
établissement on veut la marque est
profondément structurellement
spirituellement la réconciliation
franco-allemande c'est quelque chose qui
est absolument essentiel et qui doit
faire partie de notre génie national
avec 992 élèves accueillis auparavant le
lycée franco-allemand de but pour
accueillir entre 1200 et 1300 élèves
suite à cette rénovation
[Musique]